So far,
we've been focusing on the technology
aspects of information security.
However, the organization
note as assigned to aspects
are also very important.
In the next few lectures Dr.
Mustaque Ahamad is going to
cover several of these topics.
>> We're going to start with managing
cyber security in the context of
an organization.
So what is it cyber risk?
How can it reduce that risk with using
technical solutions that we discussed,
and what are the cost benefit
trade offs for example?
Once we do that, we're going to move
on to how can we have consequences for
the bad guys.
Well laws, or cyber laws in particular,
are one way to do that.
So we'll discuss some of
the US cyber laws and
then also some ethical considerations.
Then we're going to wrap up with online
privacy which is a topic that is
of great deal of interest to many of us.